[Music]
the following
is a presentation of the st louis chess
club
welcome to the corporate chess league
this is the second
exhibition match of 2021
so it's kind of like the pre-season all
they're playing for
is glory tonight and they want the glory
so we have some very exciting match-ups
tonight
we have the defending champions
enterprise they will be taking on
express scripts tonight
and we have arko versus bear
and then edward jones making their 2021
preseason debut we'll be playing on wwt
and they have a big matchup tonight and
then we have some uh
extra games as well so if you
win the the head-to-head matchups
you get a bonus 20 points and for every
game you win you get a point for that
the way these matches go there are
played
back-to-back matches it's game 10 no
delay no
increment so you'll be playing your
opponent from a different corporation
twice one with the white pieces one with
the black pieces and they're be played
back to back and then we'll get match
number two
started around seven o'clock tonight so
let's just jump right into the games
let's look at the
the reigning champions uh of the uh
corporate
chess league enterprise this was one of
their heroes
from their match against uh edward jones
moneyball in
moneyballing is playing with the white
pieces against his opponent from express
grips
moneyballin it looks according to the uh
to the scoreboard he's plus one point
so let's see what's going on they do
have opposite colored bishops
so now he's attacking the bishop so now
moneyball is probably going to have to
move and i would move it here
kind of keep some stress on the king
side
it really wouldn't be doing too much
here or there
notice uh white does have this h3 out
and his chances of being back row
checkmate
while you might say are pretty low
because he does have this escape square
look at where this queen happens to be
so if somehow
he could divert this rook from the uh
from the c line or from the back row
maybe he can get a back row check row
mate
those are always fun to do joining us in
the uh youtube commentary is the actual
hero
of uh of the final four
john boyer time boyer he's in the
youtube chat he's actually not playing
tonight
he won the big armageddon match with 0.3
seconds left
against vishal from edward jones all
right rook c2 so he has diverted
the rook from the back row so let's see
if he can uh
somehow get a back row checkmate also
this bishop could cover uh
the h square if he uh gets it there and
back again
so all right let's check out another
game from
well we gotta we gotta check on the
founder of the
corporate chess league alex corford
let's see
how his game is going
here we go he is plus
three
so the bishop just captured the bishop
and so now alex's queen is under attack
so
he'll probably want to move it to i
would say maybe all the way back but
i'll say c7 i'll see i'll see if he
stops there because then you always want
to be attacking you know
always attack that king side i know the
knights defending it i know the rook's
defending it
wow he did the old uh ben feingold
maneuver he usually ben feingold used to
do this maneuver
a lot with uh the white pieces he would
bring his queen to a4
then he would bring it back and then he
would bring it to h5
so so alex's just took the express
he went from d8 to a5
and then all the way over so the knight
is in a pin here
and now castle so you could have dreams
knight there play a little hope chest
then if this knight moves
you get checkmate
so white has got castled
all right so let's check out another uh
match
and and and edward jones
is playing wwt
all right let's check out this one
this is uh arco they're making their
their debut in the corporate chess
league and if you still want to submit a
corporation
to the corporate chess league for the
spring league
that's when things will where they're
playing for keeps you know
and and to get their name on the on the
big board
that will debut march 11th you must
submit your team
by march 1st and you do that by going to
st louis chessclub.org
and then join
and give and then you go down to this
corporate chess league
and there it is spring league
registration
click here and um register a team you do
need
four players to compete in the corporate
chess league build
and but the more the merrier i think you
can have up to 16
uh players and even if
and all games count if you bring more
more players you you can play extra
games and those
extra games if you win them they really
add up
to help your score as we'll see in the
final score tonight
i have a i have a prediction that uh wwt
brought 10 players tonight one of them
unfortunately had to drop out so they
have nine players
enterprise has eight
but enterprise does have their heavy
hitters out
tim neesham and of course the hero john
boyer time
all right let's read some of these
comments
all right whoo yeah he's back
the boy is back in town all right thank
you sir
and uh
nice haircut sir much love thank you
thank you thank you
and uh so ray do you know what uh
what saray is uh what his uh
what his handle is we can check out
saray's game if
oh here we go so let's follow him i have
a hunch he plays for
enterprise and let's see if
see if it's this gentleman
all right let's check out what he's up
to
oh we were already following his game
he's he was playing uh
alex
yep doing the attack he's got the two
bishops
yeah he's giving alex uh he's giving him
a game
all right we got d.v dutch playing for
wwt versus his opponent from edward
jones fisher of
men's fishers of men see let's see let's
just see how this one started real quick
d.v dutch playing the queen's gambit
i was told i'm supposed to say the
queen's gambit about 50 times tonight to
promote chess so
let's see let's see how it goes we're
wanna know
we'll keep a little tally here
but actually that's two for the two
mentions
all right so so both both got castled
uh white's
got all his pieces out so now fishers of
men just has to try to get
this guy out i like how he tried to do
it he's preparing b5
and then as soon as he plays b5 this
bishop will retreat and he'll play
bishop to b7 now let's see if stevie
just lets him do it
maybe he'll just say no i'm playing a5
or he made a threat
greater or equal to his own he's now
preparing
for the uh the pawn fork it's very
embarrassing to get pawn for it
because it's like how could you not see
it coming right
it's like you know how hard it is to be
pawn forked i mean you can see this
threat from a mile away all right
but i got i got faith fishers of men
from edward jones who's gonna see it
gonna retreat his queen oh or maybe not
retreat
maybe play queen to b4 attack the bishop
attack the pawn double attack
obviously white can just retreat his
bishop
or even offer a trait of queens
so he's got he's got some uh some ideas
but i'm gonna guess queen to b4
all right he played queen to c6
not too bad attacking the pawn now and
then
if he does get b5 in and then bishop to
b7
it's called a battery when the bishop
and the queen are on the same diagonal
and then look at the dream scenario
checkmate obviously i have to get this
pawn out of the way
the night out of the way but stranger
things have happened you just
put your pieces on the same line
and make tactics happen okay
all right who else do we want to see
here
yes our our nice producer uh
ben simon will uh we'll be doing the
commentary tonight on youtube
yes the time control for this event is
game 10 no delay no
increment actually on chess.com you
can't even do delay
but it's good for the viewers to know
oh so we have a time scramble here
first time scramble of the night
moneyballing from enterprise
against express scripts
so check but it's not backward checkmate
because he's got that you got to play
that instant
white one by resignation
wow well in a team event
one you never wanna resign oh
oh because he's gonna capture the the
rook
but still he's only got what 30 seconds
to checkmate you
and then you could push those pawns and
make it a stalemate
uh possibility keep that alive yeah you
want to play to the bitter end in these
games especially at team competition
so he actually did have more than one
move then i guess
but uh
put a big win in enterprises column
1-0
but i know it is kind of disheartening
when you when you do blunder and time
pressure and it's just like um i just
want to get on to the next one but
but i really like playing it out to the
bitter end i know i know our producer
ben simon does
too okay see what else we got going on
back to the dv dutch game dv dutch of
course with wwt against edward jones
let's check out another game from arko
let's see if
this gentleman is
all right so this is the captain of arko
arco construction i believe uh tommy
arko
and let's see how's it going
well the chess dot com actual scoreboard
says plus one and they are playing
bears so they're they're playing bears
board number one
bishop retreats and protects the sea
pawn
does he want to offer a trade of rooks
by retreating his bishop what else could
you do
in this position besides trying to trade
bishops you could try maybe
doubling the rooks
looks a little dangerous though but rook
here
might be the move or you could do the
famous just
h6 just just try not to get back row
checkmated
i kind of like rick d7
okay so he offers a night trade
oh uh eagle eye could get really
funny here and play rook takes
and then then obviously if knight takes
knight you just lost a piece
or if he takes back
then knight could capture the knight and
then you'd have
three minor pieces
two bishops and a knight oh and it is
played you always wanted
well not always always when i say always
i mean 95 of the time
you always want to trade two for one
oh we have breaking news ryan chester
club manager and development manager
has won his first game he was playing
one of the extra players that were
trying to accumulate more points for the
corporation
but ryan was like no way no how
not on my watch and ryan got the victory
good job ryan let's check out his uh
his extra game here
he is playing mr brady novak
unfortunately i do not know which uh
corporation
he is from so let's see so now
brady is plus one for the time
being here
they did a lot of trades on this a file
some it's a game let's check out alex
curford's game
so alex kurford
has the time advantage but according to
the computer
sarik then sarik has some shout outs in
the chat
earlier is plus one but look at that 104
that's what i'm really looking at right
now remember no
no increment so that's all you're gonna
have for the rest of the game so
oh and he's gotta pass pawn too
exciting stuff he's got dreams of rook
here
alex is in uh he's in some hurt
i like that move i i like that move by
alex try to try to
get one rid of one of these bishops oh
but yeah he's
sarik's going for the throat anyway so
he's like yeah you can take you can take
my guy
oh he protects it
i like i like ideas of oh he just pushes
the pawn
oh but what about oh he can't play
bishop to c6
wow sarik's got some moves
now notice sarik's 27's uh
rating is 1200 that is exactly what you
start at
in chess.com so i'm thinking sarik
has never played this time control
before
so really he could be he could be a
chess expert for all we know
what a follow-up removes the defender
but there's just 50 seconds left that's
why you never give up
i've seen i've seen alex
win some games by flagging uh his
opponent in
horrible horrible positions
and and good for him they're not dirty
flags a flag
is a flag a flag and a win is a win is a
win
so let's see if uh i don't really know
what uh
you know what alex has to do he's got to
just play knight takes pawn
just get rid of that get rid of his
his biggest uh threat
which is of course he's threatening to
turn a pawn into a queen
in in well essentially one square away
so yeah alex you just gotta get rid of
this guy
no he doesn't he doesn't so
he lost three points for virtually
nothing then
just eliminate the threat if you're
gonna lose a piece anyway you might as
well get a point for it
an old uh chess guy that used to work
here says
well if you can't get uh a piece for a
pawn
you're definitely doing something wrong
okay so
so 28 seconds for the week
but i don't i don't
like his chances here
takes takes now what's going on i'm the
top guester out of one zero out of three
thank you thank you thank you
oh man this guy's got to think quick how
about bishop to there
which actually loses a piece because of
g5 and unfortunately zeke
just doesn't have the time
just doesn't have the time
throwing the check roll time's sake
oh yeah there you go thread threatened
checkmate in one
all right so alex herfford with the win
fishers of men ended up taking
both games from dv dutch
fishers of men playing for of course for
uh edward jones
and db dutch playing for wwt okay we got
we got we got another game going down to
the uh the
wire this is against arko
that's cool hand luke 517 playing for
arko
versus vindy playing for bear
what is going on so it looks like
it looks like it's dead even material
obviously
he's got this bishop
black's got a lot of pawns and he's and
he
wants another pawn of a
cool hand so
i think it's just going to come down to
time here i don't think anybody's going
to give them a checkmate
might as well take and then maybe we can
swing over and give them a check
but we can block the check
or we can just take stuff bottom line if
you play
check if the king moves you're going to
win that but
i think he likes this idea because
there's no way well you can protect the
pawn with b6 for
for a matter of time but basically you
just gotta move
oh he's threatening right he is not
threatening checkmate
so we're getting some moves we're
getting some moves let's see if arko can
get on the board in their first
game he's in check
get out of check
i would just be pre-moving now just
check
yeah good another check
pre-move
remove the white needs to go here all
right no no no i meant i'm in here
obviously
oh he missed the checkmate can he do it
in a second
any move wins and any move wins cool
hand
luke 157 gets arko on the board
in their corporate chess league debut
that good for them
good for um
alex carford in with the rematch he won
on time
his first match alex corford of course
playing for edward jones the
founder of the corporate chess league
and there are a lot of corporate chess
leagues now so
if you still you still have time to join
our spring league by march 1st
by getting on st louis chessclub.org and
finding our
corporate chess league link
sign bring your team up by march
1st there will be six
games in the uh 2021
spring league there will be of course
the five regular season matches where
you accumulate
as many points as you possibly can and
then
we will play the final four on the last
match so the top four teams
get to compete to see who gets their
name
on the corporate chess league official
board
that will be uh displayed in the club
coming up quick we have it engraved it's
just the weather's been pretty bad in st
louis the last 14 days or so
we have not been able to retrieve it yet
but
rest assured enterprise has joined
the ranks of edward jones and got their
name on the board
who is it going to be in 2021
we'll just have to wait and see
all right this one's coming down to the
wire too moneyballin
with uh enterprise against express
scripts a warner
621 moneyballing with the black pieces
what's he gonna do
knight h3
a6 protect the pawn i like it whenever
you can oh but
now he got that pawn instead
can we generate any kind of attacks in
this position oh he's got to watch out a
serious threat is on the board here
i mean a serious threat you might almost
have to play
rook to here but going off that back row
could be tricky because then he could
come down here
and threaten checkmate queen the g8
checkmate if if he gets his rook to d8
so moneyballin's got got some issues
so really a6 was not probably the best
move he probably had to bring his rook
either the b6 or the d8
or even just say hey let's trade off one
of these rooks
but the computer as you see only has
i mean they have a tied game
so he's going to let the check happen
all right if you want me to check you
i'm game
and that would give him a four-point
edge according to the computer
so he plays it so
he can only really play king h8 because
he doesn't want to just lose his queen
for nothing
and now what's the big follow-up maybe
even rook f7
in this position oh i love rook f7 here
because after the queen moves i don't
care where the queen moves i'm bringing
the rook down here
and i'm just gonna say i got this
let's see if he finds rook oh so he
tripled up his uh
his pieces rook queen rook battery
and he's also threatening the big queen
takes check
so maybe he just wants to play bishop to
g7
here maybe
okay a little late unfortunately because
he can bring the rook
takes and then he's going to get checked
but maybe it's not all bad
ooh even oh so he thought he had a
tactic with
with queen takes e5 check i mean it's
good to take material who am i to blame
i mean it's all going to end up pretty
much the same i guess
but now we can get a check on the board
and now you get you're retreating one of
your attackers off the seventh row
you never want to do that
so just the little things in chess i
mean they add up
unfortunately you never want to lose
time tempo
or anything like that you just want to
improve on your position but yeah i know
and it looks so
tempting that's like how can queen takes
check
queen takes paul and check be wrong
but it just wasn't as precise
unfortunately oh and now
moneyballing goes uh pawn grabbing i
like it
so now he even up the score
and white's uh lead is slight okay so
now he got it right back so that was
cool
what what what are some ideas i really
want to attack this king
side somehow and for him oh okay well
that's an idea we'll attack
the tactic so check
he'll take back he gets the pawn
but now i get some checks in now i'm the
one
on the aggressive side big check
well that's what i'm gonna claim that he
plays and now if i'm white i just block
with the queen
but maybe i don't i don't know all right
he does it well maybe i don't because
now i'm just going to lose that pawn
that's no fun 57 seconds for
moneyballing
a little more for a warner and now he's
got his knight in the game
so he attacks the knight where do you
want to go
are you really going down here are you
really going to do it
oh and watch out what's going on now
you know his flight square is a dark
square
h2 so you've got to watch out for this
back row checkmate
if somehow his queen comes down here for
some reason
oh but he lost his uh dude
why did he lose his uh he didn't realize
that his uh
bishop was under attack so basically he
just needed to protect it with this
queen
or just move it out of harm's way
but yeah this is gonna be a tough one
for moneyball and he's
he's got 20 seconds less time if i was
him i would just play
fast and yeah just check as much as you
can
and there he got the knight right back
all right things are looking up
so now he just needs to trade everything
and call it a day call it a draw
you got to get rid of these pawns he's
got 30 seconds to do it
and does he have the time
i don't know what that that does
maybe you got to start pushing these
pawns or something
right any any check is good any check is
good just keep checking just keep
checking let's just keep moving yeah
just just try not to uh try not to
repeat too much
or else yeah chess.com will
automatically declare the game a draw
if they see the same position three
times in the game
and money ballin doesn't have any checks
oh that was his chance he needed to take
that all he needed to trade the queens
and then get his king up to attack that
pawn push the h pawn
maybe you could have got a draw that way
oh is he going to stumble into checkmate
is he going to stop
three seconds to find some kind of
miraculous checkmate
pawn fork but it was not meant to be
so we have with a big
victory against moneyballin
so they're going to end up tying 1-1
for the day so that was a scratch
so but well played
we'll go back to the uh alex crawford
match alex garford of course plays for
edward jones
playing against zariq
uh yeah unfortunately zarik
he'll probably end up if i had to bet
i am a betting man i would bet
that alex wins on time
so i
yeah yeah i i agree i agree completely
uh
john yeah yeah he just needs to pick up
the pace a little bit
i mean that's why we have these
exhibition matches
you see what you're good at see what you
need improvement with
and then you just work on that and alex
is a
great player in his own right you know
so if he if he's if he's playing this
well against it
oh epic trick check yep that's
game uh so my prediction was wrong
alex will probably win on uh by
resignation maybe
unless they told him never resign
i mean you still have three pieces you
still have two two huge uh
monster pieces the rooks heavy pieces
that
that have that have potential for the
back row checkmate
if you can somehow divert these rooks
off the back rail
you never know that's why you keep
playing yep he's gonna play the double
the rooks
but i don't think alex is gonna let him
do that i'm gonna guess that move
and i'm wrong he likes to take stuff
everybody always likes taking stuff
it looks like this is this might be the
last game in progress
ben simon ben simon you want to take a
break after this
yes okay okay okay
we will be taking a short break uh we
will probably be
back uh seven o'clock on the dot maybe a
ten minute break here and we'll try to
get some
some some big scores in it looks like
edward jones had three points
arco got on the board with uh
one point vindy did end up getting his
revenge against
cool hand it looks like
eagle eye eagle i got two points
for bear against arko
so right now that score is uh one for
our crow
three for bear and you need since they
are playing back to back and there was
four
games you would need you would need uh
four and a half points a tough match
four and a half points to uh
to get that bonus 20 points
we'll go back to the live game 10
seconds left
see if my prediction can come true let's
see if uh
alex can win on time and not resignation
three seconds two seconds all right he's
playing to the bitter
oh maybe he's gonna try to get a tactic
going like okay you take me i'll take
you or something
maybe alex will just take his rook it
seems like a move alex might make just
for fun
he'll never see it coming might win so
alex gets his
well alex took the two uh
but hartford matches for uh zariq 27
and with that victory we will bid you
adieu but we will be back we'll take a
little half time
we should be back within uh eight nine
minutes
and see ya later
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value
chess brings to our community in these
times of social distancing it's more
important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube
and twitch channels we're also holding
tournaments and private lessons online
from the comfort of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay
safe and continue to watch play and
enjoy the game of chess
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital
and preeminent global destination for
lovers of the sport
we look forward to seeing you in our new
space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 us chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and coveted 19 we were able
to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis
it was a lot of fun had a high level of
engagement
and people beginning to be attracted to
that edward
jones has been thrilled to be to help
found but also to participate in the
corporate chess league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on the corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of
you know rib each other a little bit and
and it is a little friendly banter which
we love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going that makes for
a lot of fun for people to be able to
see
how their friends how their colleagues
are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
the position and and have fun that way
too
i think during this time it is hard
to have motivation sometimes we can get
down on things
having an outlet where competition
can still be involved in your life
having an
outlet where you can still have
networking with your colleagues
has really been a key part of the
success
of the corporate chess league it has
been really fun to be able to not only
get to know the people in my own firm
better and share that that similar
passion but also get to know people from
several different firms here in in the
st
louis area we've continued to have
interest in the corporate chess league
both here in the st
louis area and beyond we're looking
forward to a great season
in 2021 if you or your company
is interested in being a part of the
corporate chess league
you can go to www.stlouischessclub.org
and get more information we'd love to
have you be a part of the competition
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever that we stay
connected to carry on that mission
we are currently offering 24 weekly
classes online through our youtube and
twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play enjoy the game of chess
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility will feature new
ground-level classrooms supporting
players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces
with state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator will provide access
for all participants and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here in the chess club
meet face to face and have games on a
quarterly basis
it was a lot of fun had a high level of
engagement and people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on the corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual uh tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of uh you know
rib each other a little bit and and it
is a little friendly banter which we
love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going
that makes for a lot of fun for people
to be able to
see how their friends how their
colleagues are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
the position and and have fun that way
too
i think during this time it is hard
for to have motivation sometimes we can
get
down on things having an outlet where
competition can still be involved in
your life having
an outlet where you can still have
networking with your colleagues
has really been a key part of the
success of the corporate chess league
it has been really fun to be able to not
only get to know the people in my own
firm better and share that that similar
passion
but also get to know people from several
different
firms here in in the st louis area
we've continued to have interest in the
corporate chess league
both here in the st louis area and
beyond
we're looking forward to a great season
in 2021
if you or your company is interested
in being a part of the corporate chess
league you can go to
www.stlouischessclub.org
and get more information we'd love to
have you be a part of the competition
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community in these times
of social distancing it's more important
than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe
and continue to watch play and enjoy the
game of chess
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator will provide access
for all participants
and allow even greater community
engagement in the great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital
and preeminent global destination for
lovers of the sport
we look forward to seeing you in our new
space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis
it was a lot of fun had a high level of
engagement
and people beginning to be attracted to
that edward jones has been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on
the corporate chess league once a month
here at edward jones we actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of
you know uh rib each other a little bit
and and it is a little friendly banter
which we love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going that makes for
a lot of fun for people to be able to
see
how their friends how their colleagues
are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
the position and and have fun that way
too
i think during this time it is hard
for to have motivation sometimes we can
get down on things having an
outlet where competition can still be
involved in your life having an outlet
where you can still have networking
with your colleagues has really been a
key part of the success
of the corporate chess league it has
been really fun to be able to not only
get to know the people in my own firm
better and share that that similar
passion but also get to know people from
several different firms here in in the
st louis area
we've continued to have interest in the
corporate chess league both here in the
st
louis area and beyond we're looking
forward to a great season in 2021
if you or your company is interested
in being a part of the corporate chess
league you can go to
www.stlouischessclub.org
and get more information we'd love to
have you be a part of the competition
[Music]
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class
chess facility the twenty thousand
square foot expansion and upgraded
facility will feature new ground-level
classrooms supporting players of all
ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces
with state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood
welcome back to round two of the
corporate chess league
exhibition number two i am your host
mike cummer international arbiter
because i forgot to introduce myself
earlier uh today
but that's who i am so my name is mike
and but more importantly
let's look at the standings well that
will be a look at them
let me tell you the standings all right
this is the preseason after all
all right with the number one team bear
with 28 points remember if you win your
match you get 20 extra bonus points so
they got 28 points bear
express scripts and number two with 26
and a half hey look at what
we got him ascension 25 points
wwt 20 points edward jones
just with 18. wow
umb 12 points
that was very generous of nicholas risco
to give him 2012 points
because they only have one guy but he's
a nice guy
enterprise has five and a half points
arko with one
and color art the ceo of color art is
playing tonight
and he's having a lot of fun he says and
uh maybe we can check out
his game uh when we get to it
we already do have a
a win on the board old path he couldn't
wait
he's like i'm gonna play right right
away right away i'm not waiting for the
official signal
so old path got his a big win
for wwt 1-0
so yeah i mean everybody five teams have
a legitimate chance to win tonight
so this is uh this is wwt's board one
darth coffee two against eagle eye
two two two zero zero one so they're off
so this is board one uh the tournament
director nicholas risco
did defeat darth coffee two
in uh his two games against uh
darth coffee so darth is probably
looking to get on the board
he's got a big rating 1917 that would be
class a
if they were going by uscf ratings so
that's very impressive to have a rating
that high
none of my ratings on chess.com were
that high so i might not even
know what i'm saying on the on about
this game
but he is playing uh very aggressive and
uh
i like it i usually like to play f3 as
well
against the uh the fiance shadow bishop
and then push my
g and h pawns in this position i would
play d5
but we'll see how what he does
because if you do take and then he takes
back you could just play queen takes
check and prevent him from castling but
his king's not really in that much
of danger without the queen on the board
i really like playing d5 here
if i was this guy i would take this in a
heartbeat
all right let's move on to uh we got a
lot of games going on
so let's go across the board oh
nick risco chest warm talk about
impressive rating 22-45 that would be a
national master rating
he is playing against kamuni
and i should know who kamuni plays for
he plays for express scripts
he's actually their number one board for
express scripts
like we said express scripts just one
and a half points off the lead of
bear
let's check out the youtube chat we are
of course
if you if you hear me yeah i'm on
youtube right now
and so hello
hello hello
let's see what else we got let's check
out the founder
is the founder plane
i do not see alex carford's game up here
yet
it might be starting a little bit slow
let's check out old path he of course
won his first match
he is playing with the black pieces his
queen is under attack by the knight
and he pretty much only well he's got c5
or d8 let's see what his big choice is
i don't know what i would do here i'd
probably go back to d8
but i don't know how are you really
going to attack me if i go to c5
well if i go to c5 i might want to
actually go to c5
but then he might be tempted to play
knight to b3 and attack the queen from
there
all right so my prediction will be
knight to b3
and then where's the queen gonna go i
guess back to uh
you could offer a queen trade or you can
just stop at f5
or even even
just d5 i would think d5 would be the
best
all right queen f3 brings out his own
queen
and now he's putting more pressure on
the knight and the knight is pinned
whenever a knight is in a pin it means
he's in an absolute pin
which means he can't move i mean it's
just
because knights don't move in a line so
when the knights of the pin he's just
stuck
so and when pieces are in pin you just
want to keep
attacking them as much as you possibly
can
all right so all paths like
just get out of this pin and now my
knight is free to roam around
cool oh
just a development manager and uh
just club manager ryan chester he is
playing with the white pieces
against juraleske
let's see who uh drew risky plays for
wwt
so this is an extra game so jeroski
could get
two points for wwt and if you see the
standings
on the screen there uh wwt needs
every point they could possibly get but
like i said
they tried to bring you could bring up
to like 16
players they tried to bring uh
at one point i thought they were
bringing 11 players
then it turns out they were bringing 10
but they
finalized with nine players tonight so
the more
more people you bring the more potential
points
so if you win your head-to-head match
you get
20 points plus uh game wins
and then if you bring more than the uh
more than the the fielded team in the in
the 20-point bonus match
you get to play extra games for up to up
to two points because you play back to
back
so see how it goes
ryan looks like he's uh doing okay
he's got he's got these pawns looking
good
he's got those double pawns
but his pawns are well he can just take
back with the rook right
but then ryan will probably win this
pawn and he does rick takes e4
so all right so let's check out uh
dv dutch he's also playing for wwt
against bear who is currently in first
place that's why we're really going to
focus on uh
this match so for a long time in eighth
in 2018 2019 uh the first two seasons of
the
corporate chess league not only did
edward jones never lose
a match i believe but they never
lost a series or you know what
a sit-down you know
when we used to have it live you know
they win
everything everything everything and
then they kept the good times rolling
in 2020 when we went virtual and kept
winning and winning winning
unfortunately they fell ever so short in
an armageddon match to determine the
final four john boyer with enterprise
came up big against michelle and got the
checkmate
with .3 seconds left to win that
they did not play the first exhibition
match in january
which is understandable and enterprise
took it
and now we could have a completely
new winner in the corporate chess league
to really get this season off to a
well pre-season and the season i mean
edward jones they might not be the top
dog anymore
they got enterprise to deal with for
sure and if
if one of these other teams bear express
ascension
wwt could come up big and win this
they could say hey we're a contender
just like you for uh
this upcoming spring season so this
could be
this could be something else it could be
a more competitive uh
season this year and that's what we like
to see
edward jones had their reign but but i
think they're just i think they're just
waiting
for that uh march 11th
and you know you know who is uh edward
jones is going to play of course
on march 11th no matter what enterprise
so we'll get a rematch right off the bat
in that matchup
and and we have a new team this season
as well uh arco construction
so here is a tommy arko playing with the
uh
black pieces against big
daddy jazz 64 from enterprise
but i think he's going to be checked in
just this oh oh
the night he's gonna get the oh yeah you
just can't resist that check
you want a knight or do you want to
check
it's tempting it's tempting and now you
can get ideas of knight to e4 he plays
it right away
and now look at this check we got
oh boy and now he's going to swing
hopefully he'll swing this rook there
and then
we might see a checkmate on the board
pretty soon here
yeah there it is and um
i uh probably yeah yeah it's it's
well he got a knight but he might get
checkmated
well that that's gonna be all they wrote
that's my guess at least yep all right
so enterprise gets on the board
but it's pre-season so it's all good
see dv dutch's game against bioproto
uh we were looking at this yeah i i
don't really know
i don't really know um they're even
material but
i mean is this is this attack gonna go
anywhere
is he ever gonna be able to get his rook
out
yeah it's it's a it's too confusing
it's too confusing we have uh whedon 80
with wwt against against
bear
so they have bears player
plus three now but is he gonna just take
it
right back nope so let's see
so he he is up in exchange he's got
two rooks and this gentleman has a
bishop
not the easiest to win but he's got five
minutes and 41 seconds
i i like i like his chances
all right but keep attacking i like it i
like it
so so smart smart man
oh ryan chester
he's got a lot of pieces he's got a lot
of pieces
and he's got made in 15 if he only knew
it but
not anymore plus 64 though that's a good
number now he's got made in seven
i don't see it though
two rooks and a bishop against the rook
i think ryan can convert this in
two and a half minutes oh we'll go back
to board one
that that might set the tone for this
match against wwtn baird wwt's player is
darth coffee too
but it looks like he might be down a
piece
it might be down a whole rook to be
honest with you
even though the computer only has them
plus
three what is going on am i just missing
a rook
oh he just lost his knight though that's
why you never give up never surrender
so he retreated and then then yeah when
he moved
he he saw the pin he got out of it
so now uh eagle eye is only up in
exchange
oh but darth coffee has a couple more
pawns it looks like for the exchange
so yeah i'm liking white in this
position
uh you got those two bishops
you got the extra pawn the only problem
with these pawns is
is none of them are past pawns so
all right good morning
well it's uh it's 7 25
usa central time we are broadcasting
live
from the st louis chess club in saint
louis missouri
usa
oh let's see if oh chess worm
he's got he's got this game uh nick
risco and
a resignation is on the board
we haven't really checked out this game
too much we have
vindi who is plus 19
and uh he always threatening knight to
c2 checkmate let's see if he can figure
out a way out of it he does not
so we are going to see a night checkmate
so vindy wins vindy where are you
at vindy
bendy won for bear
oh let's see the end of this confusing
confusing game okay so it doesn't look
as confusing anymore
oh he's got work to e6 forking the pawns
he's gonna see it he's got to see it
yeah there it is it's on the board
so dv dutch who uh
didn't get on the board in round number
one but it's a team game is the rest of
his
guys helped him out
and uh which one do you want
i'll take this one
yeah yeah i'll take that one that way i
have a pass pawn then
cause this guy's already passed anyway
oh wow one by resignation i did not see
that one coming
there's a lot of ways you can get a
stalemate with a rook
uh possibly if you make amends
well oh well
a good one for a tv dutch beats bio
proto
1-0 and so
in my book so far uh wwt is off to a
good start 2-0
but let's check out the end of the board
one game
wow what happened to uh the bishop
the bishop went bye-bye and uh
this is not gonna work out well for
uh so he had this nice bishop
oh and then he voluntarily removed
the protector and
did not work out well for him and yeah
uh
eagle eye is gonna win this one for sure
oh the old path game who's got made in
three
according to the computer there's one
now he's got made in six made in four
so it looks like ella maxia will get his
revenge
ella maxier playing for bear the
top seed but yeah that's why you play on
you've got you've got to get rid of this
pawn though i mean you've got to either
get rid of it or make it stuck
so you can you can get that stalemate
you got to be trying for that stalemate
that's my guess that's correct oh right
but you've got to play
h4 or else there's no reason to keep
playing unless unless you want to run
this guy out of time
that way you get the full point you get
the full point if the guy runs out of
time
and you still have this pawn if the guy
runs out of time
or obviously stalemates you there you go
uh i would just take that risk i'd
rather have i'd rather try to win by
stalemate
or not win i'd rather try to tie my
stalemate
than keeping my pawn on the board
and eliminate my chance of a stalemate
uh
draw if that makes any sense to anybody
let me know
but yeah you want to get rid of the pawn
now this guy should take the guy's pawn
especially with check now
that way he secures a draw for himself
even if he runs out of time
because obviously a king is not
sufficient
checkmating material oh but he's
living on the edge living on the urge
so so if old path
uh wins on time and he has that pawn he
actually will win
get the full point for this even up but
it wasn't meant to be elemexia got his
revenge and gets
a bear on the board
good games good games
yeah i mean very friendly very cordial
league but uh
it's more fun to play this obviously in
person
and then they could go over the game
exchange business cards
further pleasantries and uh maybe make a
business contact i mean that's what it's
all about
and and to hang out with your teammates
beforehand
is uh is joyous as well we always have
uh
the finest meats and cheeses as they say
and uh and a lot of fun but
hey we'll take it we'll take it all
right
we go from old path to old loser he is
playing
enterprises moneyball in
enterprise is playing
now this might be an extra game against
old loser or they might be they might
just be playing
for fun so
we're gonna get away from uh
this matchup
and we'll go to the uh
whedon 80.
so whedon is playing with the white
pieces it doesn't look
very good for him he's down on time
but you know there goes his bishop but
he's got
he's trying to get that he's trying to
get that queen so never stop never stop
stopping
but he can just bring his rook back up
and that should be
oh let's see if he can find that move
work h to aj
there's no reason nope so he's going to
lose a rook
and then he'll have 47 seconds to try
and get the checkmate
but i like his chances but
maybe he can try for that stalemate it's
going to be tough to try to stalemate in
this one
but he wants he wants to get that pawn
rook to a1 is probably the best move
check
just check oh well you don't want to
check them there
it's just going to run them out of time
so whedon
loses the first one whedon 80 was
playing for wwt
so bear it looks like it's
2-2 by my count
oh well i'm not i'm not counting this
eagle i
did end up winning that game against
darth coffee this is their second game
so bear actually takes the lead with
three points against wwt
so wwt if they if they actually want to
win not just this match but the whole
the whole exhibition
they're going to need to come up big in
these rematches
so what is going on we got a pin on the
knight here
we got castled i i don't really like how
far my pawn
is though uh
if i well yeah he had my attacks
i mean your king might be kind of safe
in the center here if you want to try to
just attack
you know that's what i would do i mean
you're here to have fun you're here for
the exhibition but yeah i mean gasoline
is
is sound it's probably the best move
actually but
sometimes you just want to want to have
fun and just
just just you know go for the king you
know
i mean that's the name of the game
checkmate
get him
ryan chester did win that first one when
he had the big
lead with the two rooks and a bishop
against just the rook
and uh looks like he's doing pretty well
pretty well again
he's got more pawns
one two three so he's got one more pawn
and now he's going to take the h pawn
attack
uh oh you might want to you might want
to play
pawn here that way you can protect the
rook and then get out of this pin
somehow somehow some way
and then we got nick risco playing
against
kamuni
and it looks like he's doing pretty well
he's got this rook and uh
he's got this rick in a pin and it looks
like he's gonna gonna win the work
back to good old let's see if we didn't
can get his revenge
in this game we'll start we'll start it
from the top according to the computer
we got a london system
not the queen's gambit thank you very
much
all right and
[Music]
castle
so he's protecting his pawn with the
pawn he might have dreams of h4 as well
if this knight ever moves he might try
to
threaten checkmate on h7 so
we'll see big big game for bear here
let's see if we can find another one of
a
bear's players here
all right we did follow we did fi we did
find another game
so uh it looks like wade wade s
i don't want to say his last name but he
used to be uh huge
in the uh st louis community i've known
wade since uh by 1996
i think back at the old old white cliff
park chess club on thursday nights
he was there represent yep
and then he he actually he carried the
the
the banner for uh st louis
uh st
louis uh tournaments he held tournaments
over in uh
brentwood the uh the ice rink
down there so that was fun
first saturday of even months
tournaments and he's still he's still
doing well he's got his he's got his uh
knight forking the rook so
looks like he might win this one
and he's definitely better than a 10 29
that's for sure
i don't know why what the computer
thinks is going to happen
but
all right we'll take the guy
unless they think that knight's gonna
get trapped that's the only thing i can
think of
and maybe it will
i don't know what wade is thinking about
i mean okay your night's gonna get
trapped but you want to wick
i mean i mean if you move one of these
knights
uh the other night's gonna get captured
so you might yeah you might as well i
mean
so he's gonna take the one on c2 and now
you can always defend it too
wade with rick to look to there
and then you just gotta hope
because he's got one two moves
so he's gonna tr well he's got it one
two
and then he's gonna have to move the
rook over
yeah i i i think uh i think this
knight's gonna be a-okay
but we'll see wade's bigger issue
is uh his time here two and a half
minutes to win this
unless you start picking up the pace
it's gonna be tough
so king f1 okay uh oh he
keeps playing oh so he's going to try to
get it out
like that interesting
i don't know if that's going to work oh
you got it just in the nick of time
wade of course is playing with wwt
against the uh
the first place team right now
well going into the round bear but
the bear's looking pretty strong right
now
let's see if uh alex carford i don't
know what happened to alex here
we haven't heard a anything from edward
jones let's just see if
any edward jones games are even going on
king taker he's a he's a good exciting
player
unable to follow him
no such luck
oh what a move by wade knight takes f2
and now knight there and that should be
the game
you can just consolidate to an easy easy
easy
endgame victory there it is
we might give him the game of the day
wwt but but it's in it's inc
it's in consideration we're getting late
in the night here
we only have uh a couple games still
going
and two of them are by uh
chess associates nick riska or chess
chess employees let's say club manager
ryan chester
and and the
tournament director for tonight nicholas
risco let's see if ryan can force a draw
here
he is playing with the black pieces
but he's only has 27 seconds left to
somehow get it oh and the guy just gave
it to him
so he'll kindly take it
draw the king so so good games by ryan
ryan finishes strong
three and a half out of four for the
night good job
and a very enthusiastic good game
so cool and i want to thank uh
thank uh well ryan and nick
for uh and of course lauren stewart for
uh
putting this all together and uh tara
meyer with uh
the chess matrix
so good game and and uh
and we can't wait for to start the uh
2021 spring chess
league march 11th you still have time
still have time if you're if you're
watching and want to get your
corporation involved
you have until march 1st to uh to get
your team over to uh
the development managers lauren stewart
and ryan chester
and they can help you out and get it
rolling
all right so this is board one of
of the wwt against bearer match
darth coffee 2 is representing wwt and
bear is represented by eagle eye
two two two zero zero one
and wades did end up winning that game
and then yeah that was
yep and that was that was all he
that was all that wrote so yeah it was
it was a very exciting they look like
hey
one his night might get stuck down there
but but wade had the idea
just push that e pawn down don't there's
no reason to protect it with the
rook over and uh and this was the move
boom you just take the pawn and then
once it takes
knight g4 offering to trade everything
we're going to definitely trade
something so he got it
and then he got the game so
keeping wwt alive in theory at least
against barrett looks like
with his two wins
so right now i see the score
if i can do right
one two four points
for wwt and three points
for bear
and once nick risco
gets done with this game he can start
updating the scores
and we'll get on with the uh
we'll get on with the official final
tally
yeah good games uh alomexia we got to
see
uh we got to see your uh your games
against uh
old path you got you got the uh
you got your revenge in game number two
that was good
yeah if anybody's watching youtube right
now and they were like
oh man if you thought wade's game was
good
check this game out i do not want to
tell you what the prize is because then
you might not
uh might not submit it but yeah if you
if somebody has a really good game in
the in the chat uh
go ahead and i'll pull it up while we're
uh waiting for the uh
for the final tally
yeah so these are the standings just
going into the round
obviously bear got got
a few more points as
as this wwt at
right now
db dutch ended up taking both of them
so we can add another point to uh
to wwt so wwt they might
they probably won't win even if they win
this contest because it was so
so contested that they didn't have
enough to uh
to overtake the other teams but i guess
we'll never know
but it's going to be tough to you get
the bonus 20 so that will
bring him at 40 it can assuming they win
but probably going to only end up with
like 48
points it might take 50 to win this
thing
it it could come down to uh this could
be close
nick risco's got to get his game over
with so we can start
start tallying them up
so right now in this in this wwt bear
match i have a
i have wwt
with five worldwide technology is what
they're actually called
and then bear only has three by my count
let's see if there's a one more game to
uh to look at here
um that game is over with
all right so but we do have the board
one battle
darth coffee two playing for wwt against
eagle eye for bear
eagle eye got the first one
darth man that minute 09 you just gotta
make
some moves i mean this is a position i
mean there's i mean you just gotta move
i mean you're in the middle game
uh you gotta just you just gotta go just
start
taking stuff and getting on with the
show and
you gotta hope something big happens
quick
oh here we go okay this is the live
position now
52 seconds they still have a lot of
pieces on the board
this is going to be a tough one white's
king
it's going to be very difficult to get
this guy checkmated
this guy is uh you might want to try
just that to just
try and try and get something going
all right get your password going i like
that idea
just well yeah you got to you got to
protect that guy
but if you protect that guy you can't
really protect them i guess that guy's
gone
get that bishop out to get this rook in
the game but
with this uh with this time ticking down
it's
it's gonna be near impossible for this
guy to come up
big
yeah sometimes it's just
yeah you lost your pawn and well well
queen oh big check oh that gives him a
chance to uh
to block
so after queen takes c6
his rook will be under attack but at
least you got something going
now now now
get some checks on the board you push
that pawn stranger things have happened
but this is gonna take a yeah a point
one
that's why you never you never you never
give up
all right uh so bear gets another point
on the board
so it looks like all the games
probably have been concluded
we will be back you want to do the uh
you want to do the best game prize now
or when we come back
oh actually actually we have a
we have we have um
we will uh do the best game prize when
we come back and get the whole final
stance
because we do have another game to check
on so
let's go from there since 2009
our mission has always been to teach and
promote the value chess
brings to our community in these times
of social distancing it's more important
than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online
through our youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online
from the comfort of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastica tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility will feature new
ground-level classrooms supporting
players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces
with state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades
including a new three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow even greater community
engagement in the great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup st louis rapid and
blitz and more
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to the pandemic
and covet 19 we were able to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis it was a
lot of fun
had a high level of engagement and
people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on
the corporate chess league once a month
here at edward jones we actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of uh you know
uh rib each other a little bit and and
it is a little friendly banter which we
love and all during that time the st
louis chess club is hosting a youtube
channel
that has commentary from guest speakers
grand masters
international masters commentating on
how the games are
actually going that makes for a lot of
fun for people to be able to
see how their friends how their
colleagues are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
uh the position and and have fun that
way too
i think during this time it is hard
for to have motivation sometimes we can
get down on things having an
outlet where competition can still be
involved in your life having an outlet
where you can still have
networking with your colleagues has
really been
a key part of the success of the
corporate chess league
it has been really fun to be able to not
only get to know the people in my own
firm
better and share that that similar
passion but also get to know people from
several different firms here in in the
st louis area
we've continued to have interest in the
corporate chess league
both here in the st louis area and
beyond
we're looking forward to a great season
in 2021
if you or your company is interested
in being a part of the corporate chess
league you can go to www
dot louis and get more information
we'd love to have you be a part of the
competition since 2009
our mission has always been to teach and
promote the value
chess brings to our community in these
times of social distancing it's more
important than ever that we stay
connected to carry on that mission
we are currently offering 24 weekly
classes online through our youtube and
twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative
digitally
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit bed workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay
safe and continue to watch play enjoy
the game of chess
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages as well
as expanded tournament and community
gathering spaces with state-of-the-art
technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow
even greater community engagement in the
great game of chess
as a proud resident of the central west
end neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital
and preeminent global destination for
lovers of the sport
we look forward to seeing you in our new
space in 2021
when we will host the 2021 u.s chess
championships
2021 u.s juniors and senior
championships
the same field cup saint louis rapid and
blitz and more
[Music]
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to
the pandemic and covet 19 we were able
to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis it was a
lot of fun
had a high level of engagement and
people beginning
to be attracted to that edward jones has
been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on the corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual uh tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of uh you know
uh rib each other a little bit and and
it is a little friendly banter which we
love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going that makes for
a lot of fun for people to be able to
see
how their friends how their colleagues
are doing
during a game by having a professional
be able to speak about
the position and and have fun that way
too
i think during this time it is hard
to have motivation sometimes we can get
down on things
having an outlet where competition
can still be involved in your life
having an
outlet where you can still have
networking with your colleagues
has really been a key part of the
success of the corporate chess league
it has been really fun to be able to not
only get to know the people in my own
firm
better and share that that similar
passion but also get to know people from
several different firms here in in the
st louis area
we've continued to have interest in the
corporate chess league both here in the
st
louis area and beyond we're looking
forward to a great season
in 2021 if you or your company
is interested in being a part of the
corporate chess league
you can go to www.stlouischessclub.org
and get more information we'd love to
have you be a part of the competition
welcome back to the corporate chess
league exhibition number two
we are wrapping up nick risco is putting
it in the final stando we got to see
their
win tonight and then carla art you know
you bring one guy
you lay it all on the line and uh
sometimes that's what happens
but he had a very fun time he told me so
so that's that's great for him if you
still want to sign up a
team for uh for the spring league
2021 we'll have uh five matches and the
final four
you still have until march 1st to sign
up on st
louis chessclub.org see ya
march 11th for the spring league
good night
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club
you